dans le département de l'eure la
solidarité a payé une femme angolaise et
sa fille entrées en france de manière
irrégulière ne seront pas expulsés
le collège où la fillette est scolarisée
depuis plusieurs années s'était
fortement mobilisée ils étaient en grève
aujourd'hui
karine henry et eric lombard on lui
laissait entrevoir un avenir meilleur
l'espoir fut de courte durée
carmen à 17 ans elle est scolarisée à
evreux la jeune fille est arrivée en
france il ya quatre ans sa maman a
quitté l'angola où leurs vies étaient
menacées
elle vit au jour le jour dans
l'incertitude administrative
carmen et sa maman sont menacés
d'expulsion depuis plusieurs mois
professeurs et élèves se sont mobilisés
pour demander leur régularisation
l'espoir est venue de jean louis debré
le maire d'evreux a décidé de s'engager
personnellement il n'y a pas d'expulsion
ni pour carmen ni pour sa mère et nous
allons maintenant nous occuper et longue
durée pour que les choses se passent
bien le soulagement puis la déception
quelques heures plus tard le préfet de
l'eure tient un discours bien différent
certes il confirme qu'il ne procéderait
à aucune action de force mais il ne voit
aucune raison dans ce dossier pour
régulariser ou délivrer un titre de
séjour il est là dit il pour appliquer
la loi
je n'ai aucune raison de faire une
régularisation
par contre il ya des procès notamment
celle de l'aide au retour volontaire qui
peut lui être proposé dans des délais
qui sont tout à fait négociable
donc je pense qu'il peut y avoir un
dialogue mais le droit est stricte et le
droit c'est celui effectivement d'une
reconduite à la frontière
gbc prennent dans les bras il peut faire
tout ce que peut dire ce qu'est ce que
vous mais j'ai jamais baissé les bras
qui est asean en porte encore que ma
mère y si je le ferai
les professeurs sont écoeurés carmen
effondré sa maman vit cachée quelque
part la jeune fille n'a pas de nouvelles
depuis plus d'une semaine
elle ne comprend pas pourquoi le préfet
refuse de leur donner des papiers